[Music]
and sure why not news submitted by shut
up Chad shut up thank the level guy get
there Chad all the Chad's are watching I
hate what I do
hey man Chad's are under attack though
man yeah you're born with the wrong name
already yeah chat up is Ted short for
anything
chatter dumb short for douchebag I think
a man being fired brought an emotional
support clown to you was gonna get fired
so he brought a motion to support clown
[ __ ] dope you can have an emotional
support clown with me on like in the
grocery store [ __ ] like people do with
their dog I think it's part of I mean
it's part of the Disabilities Act and
people aren't even allowed to question
the emotional support cloud that's so
funny can I take one on the plane with
me doctor buy a seat for him
no you might have to buy a seat for that
cuz I don't think he could lap it I've
seen someone lap a husky before Wow the
whole play I'm like that's [ __ ] crazy
that must be warm maybe I could get an
emotional support [ __ ] clown and then
I could take them on a plane yeah and
then I could lap him yeah me just come
in on Little People little bill little a
little person I saw a documentary where
they were like no I want to be called
[ __ ] one of them so thank you for
though I don't speak for everybody I'm
pretty insistent that they're
regular-sized in other areas okay grace
to this to their credit I vouch for them
oh thank you man he thought like he was
notified that he was gonna be having a
redundancy meeting which means he will
be getting fired
what doesn't see me it means it's like
when you're getting being let go I look
this up so it's like a UK and a New
Zealand thing like a euphemism like hey
man you're redundant that's [ __ ] up
Oh and New Zealand this guy she's
working at an ad agency so he decided
you know what this is
this will be fun you know because he was
allowed to bring one person for
emotional support so he he'll bring like
a friend a colleague if I'm family
members guys awesome or just anyone
right oh you could bring people to the
meeting that's a that's a coin you might
cry did you bring a cheerleader and he
did the best location of speaker maybe
like we were lawyers yeah that lawyer
for you okay I would bring a bunch of
people and have them clap after
everything I said one person oh you can
bring one who's your brain Nicky Nicky
you wouldn't be good for emotional
support I bring a little little fish in
a fishbowl yeah my mo support you cry
while you hold the bowl apparently it's
pretty good yeah one that cusses yeah
that says what you want to say in the
meeting it's like look I understand I'm
being like oh yeah let's go there's like
a skit like that right yeah we should
bail isn't it or the Obamas oh yeah yeah
interpreter what are the kid feeling you
know key and Peele okay Chappelle huh I
mean everything my name though I thought
you just saved right people look to save
that's why I heard that's what I heard
I'll just try to help you out with what
you were trying to say myself out he's
hilarious so I give him credit for that
I heard Tiff's say all n-words like the
same that's why her started to say but
she didn't say n word I'll tell you that
so this clown Harry's name is Joe the
clown and he's usually he's this 26 year
old that's usually hired for children's
parties
[ __ ] that [ __ ] scared I don't like young
clowns so this is a photo from their
redundancy meeting yes the type of
getting a convo he looks
wearing makeup you gotta wear the makeup
Lisbon no is he the the no missed
opportunity they have the big shoes
please tell me how the big shoes I can't
see them but right now cuz he's
disappointing clown what about the does
he had the flower that shoots water and
you could shoot the water when he came
in he was dressed normally and then
right before the meeting started he went
to the bathroom to put on his mats
dubbed the makeup no balloon no makeup
that's not a real clown not a clown not
a real clown of my clown this guy's a
clown yeah unless he strikes fear and my
soul he's not a clown yeah he has to be
scary as [ __ ] like a it but the egg car
that guy looks scary see I think it
clowns just in general just just
standing there like this just prom [ __ ]
that I'm already scared yeah Ronald
McDonald is [ __ ] scary
don't clown scary into that you don't
have the need to beat their ass when you
just see a clown I do when I see one I
want to punch one yeah you never thought
they were scary never that's cuz you
have a cool part maybe I want to kick
him in the nuts honk their [ __ ] nose
and punch him in the stomach in that
order my cousin in Mexico and I was
living out there she was doing she was
being a clown for kids parties as like a
side thing and I'm like that's cute all
Mexican clowns are okay I'm cool at
Mexican what do they look like they look
different they're usually like red white
and green you better not do white they
better not do white face I'll tell ya
she had like red cheeks but there's like
a there's like a movie coming out where
it's like about a clown without that
people hire to like scare their kids
[ __ ] wrinkles are some shell trailer for
it and I thought but it's a like a [ __ ]
yeah where's the cloud you kill him no
he they hired the con to scare their
kiss behaving children yeah but they say
that without once once he enters your
life like he kind of like stays involved
in your life that's that's why he's a
stalker he's a stalker and he starts
like getting too involved like staying
in the house he kind of want to watch
this it's dark it's a document but like
they make no they made it look like if
it was a doc is it real I mean actual
documentary
I'll do like I think they set it up that
way so that you can go like a Blair
Witch Project
they definitely gave it some sizzle to
it so it looks like a horror movie when
you're watching it but it's a
documentary about the clown and the guy
who does the clown for years and [ __ ] hi
is he stick around here like he feels
scary dude he's got like like like a
droopy eye kind of like he's like you
know like when you go outside and he's
like peeks head up behind a fence and
[ __ ] it's a documentary Eric watch the
trailer and he thought it was a real
movie what a idiot ha ha ha oh this is
great how it's packaged sorry
ok there's been like Blair Witch [ __ ] no
no come to ways [ __ ] bully ways dude
[ __ ] they did a lot to that trailer to
make it look like it was tell me you
don't want to beat his ass yeah but when
I see things like that I want to destroy
it yeah I want to stab them it's like a
I don't know it's like a bunch of worms
in a bucket like you just want to smash
they don't get scared by that TIFF no it
doesn't make you feel weird
it makes her hoarding it makes you horny
no hope there's a viral video of him get
on he was underneath like to see Ellen
he's underneath the kids bed what it's a
documentary I mean that's so real got a
tweet saying that we talked about on JK
news before cuz I did see this face and
they're like did you talk about this guy
but I didn't look into it and then now
you're bringing it up I'm like oh yeah
someone so we talked about this they're
doing a great job marketing this though
yeah they're they're making it sound
like it just came from mike scioscia me
what a great way to pair it yeah is it
the Japanese do it pretty good yeah with
the dinosaur that looks real and they
just tease his people down the [ __ ]
hall I love it I love that or the ghost
what was it like Bobby's goes yeah cuz
Dobby TV shows of like kids misbehaving
and then they'll bring in like ghosts
that come in and tell them they have to
go to sleep and all that and the kid I
love that [ __ ]
see that's the right way to juice it
because then you're on the team of the
attacker yeah I mean normally when I see
some [ __ ] youtuber person just
[ __ ] harassing their kid it's like
your dick dude yeah well like when you
show me the kids being a [ __ ] first
I'm like yes [ __ ]
yeah they do that they show what [ __ ]
garbage cans the kids are like jumping
up and down smacking the parents in the
face while they're trying to sleep and
you're like these brats are gonna get it
and then the ghost comes out and then
the ghost is like wearing a g-string and
a [ __ ] he's very like a g-string and
then like he's wearing a like like a he
has a bloody face and like long hair and
no he's ball at the top
he's like my dentist ring yeah he's a
rape ghost
what's the g-string about sexy goes it
could have been just as effective
without the G I think it's a traditional
underwear
wrestlers underwear I'm just scared that
he's in a g-string it looks like a
rapier rapist or something that's not
because he's a ghost to theater that's a
fetish makes me think of like la you're
not have you guys heard of like you
don't know the Mexican folk tale like
the the evil like spirit that comes to
haunt the kids and that's something that
like my grandma has used against me like
did you go to sleep or leave the sleeper
Kukui like all that [ __ ] what's good man
Oh boogey man for me it was like Santa
Claus is not gonna come I'm like dude
it's [ __ ] it's like October
right now I'm true that would have
terrified me I'm gonna [ __ ] about
getting the gift yeah yeah so this
emotional support clown here maybe even
news all over the place cuz they were
like damn that's funny this guy has a
sense of humor and then never saying
that did he get rehired after that ah
this guy's funny no so he didn't he
doesn't now have a job at another age
agency at agency but they were
mentioning that during the meeting the
people firing the dude was just like huh
anyway so yeah maybe give a [ __ ] yeah
then you can they didn't care so oh and
then also he was making balloon animals
oh that's pretty good dude they should
just have a whole entire business on
this like emotional support characters
I'd like a wizard that cast spells on
the people while I'm like getting fired
right the fact that you got to know
you're about to be fired
here it's a surprise it's like Oh
but well maybe they don't want to like
make them to panicky no but I think it's
it's a good thing because then you could
prepare things and like sorry applying
other places it's like a courtesy just
like hope oh you know what just like
hell when you're you're quitting from a
job they require a two weeks notice what
the [ __ ] you can't give me a two weeks
notice of getting fired I never got
fired so I don't know the process I've
never gotten fired either just saying
you sounded like it was you taking a
purse away I was like oh [ __ ] does she
get fired like that cuz I'm thinking
that's not fair if the employer needs to
have a notice why can't the employee
have enough because I that's what I
thought is that when you do get fired
they tell you like when your end date
was C I don't know see I think sometimes
layoffs they give you severance and then
you're like oh cool so then they laid
off one but sometimes you want to fire
them immediate like imagine you guys had
an editor for your channel and they
repeatedly put out stuff that you don't
you told them not to put out about your
guys's life and then if you have another
two weeks they can keep putting out more
stuff cuz they're just Dada clueless
this year right now get the hell out of
here did you either [ __ ] it on my ship
there's a lot of rules to that too -
firing it's really difficult to do that
in California well especially France
dude you want to fire somebody in France
that's why you don't even start a
business in France they got all kinds of
[ __ ] rules about business over there
that's why they're very lazy in France
French women yeah guys what are you
giving me do you want to smoke
cigarettes eat [ __ ] bread and just
relax
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you